wake up the job at the bow don't sweat
now swell
and she tolerates ability Tony you gonna
burn my
I'm going
I'm a wall
it's 1969 the year of Woodstock man
landing on the moon and it's the height
of the Cold War and while in the real
world nuclear war between America and
the Eastern Bloc was averted in fallout
those tensions merely continued America
essentially reinvented itself reshaping
its 50 states into 13 Commonwealth's the
theory was that in a bid not to let
communism seep into the country thirteen
United Commonwealth's would help the
nation better meet the challenges posed
by the communist threat to American
democracy five in reality it just
created even more political strife in
the American government increasing the
paranoia and state of unrest in an
already fragile country and the plan
appears to have worked well at least in
the sense that none of the 13
Commonwealth turned communist and in 80
years that followed fallouts America had
made some progress to the mounting
tensions and potential for nuclear war
had spurred the country to escalate the
space race as well as make incredible
strides in the fields of AI robotics one
of the great minds behind these
advancements is robert house
born in 2020 house would go on to found
robco which was responsible for much of
the technology you see in the wastelands
of fallout robco invented the protect
runs the Sentry BOTS the giant Liberty
Prime and even a little wearable
computer known as the pip-boy so yeah
house is one of the major players in the
Fallout universe we'll talk about him
more in a future episode
so while America managed to safeguard
itself from the threat of communism make
significant technological strides
create a new best-selling color drink it
wasn't so hot on you know sorting out
the whole nuclear war thing in April
twenty fifty two we enter a period in
history known as the resource wars
dependent on the ever depleting reserves
of crude oil and fossil fuels Europe
wages war with the Middle East over the
remaining fuel reserves a great panic
and paranoia spread across the world
America invades Mexico it annexes Canada
and sets up front lines to defend oil in
Anchorage while China marches in to
Alaska this resource war ultimately was
the spark that would go on to set off
the nukes but before that let's talk
about the vaults in 2054 with
international tensions and all-time high
the United States government backed by
the secretive Enclave organization
commissioned vault-tec and Rob Cohen
streets to begin project safehouse this
involved building 122 public vaults
dotted across America each designed to
shelter 1,000 individuals from a nuclear
Cataclysm that's what what the official
story was anyway in reality and the
vaults were part of a series of secret
experiments orchestrated by the United
States government each vault was the
basis of a completely different social
experiment vault 68 for example is
populated with 999 men and a single
woman involved 34 there was an over
stocked armory which happened to have no
lock on the door and in terms of
providing safety and security if their
inhabitants most of the vaults have
proved to be complete failures with
vault sex experiments being their true
motives meant that the vaults were never
really designed solely for the
protection of their dwellers that brings
us to the fateful date of October 23rd
2077 the day the bombs fell pizza and
protracted wars over resources ended
with countries launching nukes at each
other
the exchange lasted just two hours the
vast majority of the world's population
perished entire species were wiped out
and contaminated black rains followed
for months after the nukes fell in the
scattered remains of the people and
forces of the world tribes and
settlements are formed one of those
being the Brotherhood of Steel
you know those tech loving guys in
hulking power armor fallout for the
latest entry in the saga starts the
announcement the attack and a sudden
rush to the vault with your family while
warheads fly across the sky this is the
first time that fallout has allowed you
to play through a sample of pre-war life
the original Fallout game is set
sometime later in the year 2161 your
character is known as the vault dweller
sent from vault 13 into the South
California wasteland you begin a quest
to recover a new computer chip for the
vaults water system before it's
drinkable resources deplete entirely
after spending a year in the wasteland
securing clean water for your vault and
being labeled a hero in the process your
reward for all your hard work is
that's right the overseer in charge of
all thirteen fear that you wielded too
much influence so they cash you out into
the wastelands
but in crisis lies opportunity and the
vault dweller then founds a new village
Arroyo in 2197 the events surrounding
Fallout Tactics begin the game set in
Chicago tasks a Brotherhood of Steel
squad to free a village from a tribe of
troublemakers from cannibals to super
mutants to an entire robot army led by
an AI called the calculator which is
based in the mysterious vault zero after
a year of combat a leader of the
Brotherhood merges brains with the
calculator to bring a new age of peace
for the surrounding survivors then in
2241 some 80 years after the setting of
the original game the story of Fallout 2
begins we're back in Arroyo which is
suffering the worst drought in its
history the village elder asks the
descendant of the vault dweller known as
the chosen one to find and return a
Garden of Eden Creation Kit
or ghek this is a device that can create
living thriving life from the soil of
the wasteland the chosen one arm to the
pit boy mm searches vault 13 first the
closest location for a ghek but finds it
devoid of life it's not the best news
for the chosen one as they discover upon
returning to their village that it has
been captured by the enclave who are
basically the decaying remnants of the
pre-war US government who gather
unwilling test subjects to experiment on
but we'll talk more on those guys
another day in a bit of battle that
lasts a whole year the chosen one uses
an oil tanker to destroy the enclaves
offshore base and thus freeing the
village of Arroyo fallout 3 is set 17
years later in 2258 it's been nearly two
centuries since the bombs fell and it's
time for a new hero with a new story
that hero is the lone wanderer raised in
vault 101 by their father James but by
the time the lone wanderer turns 19
James unexpectedly ventures into the
wasteland sending vault 101 and it's
paranoid overseer into disarray the lone
wanderer spends a year venturing out of
the vault in search of their father
along the way discovering the town of
Megaton the charismatic three dog and
the wastes of Washington DC partway
through the journey Jane
found suspended in stasis upon freeing
him it's discovered that he left the
vault to activate project purity a water
purifying system that could bring fresh
clean h2o to the entire wasteland after
activating the system the lone wanderer
joins the Brotherhood of Steel
continuing to provide pure water to the
wasteland and hunt the enclave remnants
before fading into legend but in the
world of fallout peace never lasts the
year is 22
to deliver a package to new vegas he's
shot in the head the details of that
package and how it affects the entire
city of new vegas is something we are
going to explore in depth at a later
time because this story can end in one
of four ways each with its own
sacrifices and alternate implications
for the city of new vegas we're gonna be
playing through every game in the
Fallout franchise and the build-up to
fallout 4 itself and starting next week
Dave's gonna go right back to the very
beginning with fallout 1 but we want you
to get involved to give us your best
ideas for character names gender builds
stab perks the whole deal in the box
below and the ones we use in the show
we'll get some lovely prizes we can be
playing through the entrance fallout 1
and searching for a very specific canine
companion but until next week you can
find me on twitter at a regular Dave and
I'm at Lucy James game and I'll see you
next time wasteland err
with the bow loose wet-naps well
you got into beautiful Tony gonna burn
my troubles away I'm going